can the person who has had sex in an
office please step
forward my first guest that did not have
sex in an office was maray because they
in a relationship and not to say that
they couldn't have had it before the
next person that I thought did not have
sex in an office um even though they did
say that they were a bit of a rule
breaker and it's fun Sophia the next
person that I thought maybe didn't
either was Chris I will cry if that's
the right one the next two that I
thought could be between would be Diana
and Mia so I'm going to go with Diana
I'm sorry Diana's parents can the person
who has had sex in an office please step
forward I'm
sorry I was really stressed out I was
really stressed I've been thinking about
it like all week yeah